hey everybody welcome to behind the
scenes now some of you may have noticed
some of these are finally looking our
seat cards in our video on these cool
little mini drums these are actually
called the parrot mini-drone since
called the jumping sumo made by her
this is a awesome RC company we're
actually going to be giving some of
these away for you guys and you go how
do you how to get these in order to
enter go to our Facebook page
facebook.com slash corridor digital and
you'll see a post from video click on
that share button we get a long list of
names and we're going to pick three
random people to win either one of these
mini drums or jumping sumo good luck so
we set out to do this miniature Mad Max
style RC chase battle scene and we
thought you know we'll get a bunch of
sweet RC vehicles and we'll just fill
them as if it's a miniature car chase
easy right
it's the most surprising thing about
filming an RC car action sequence is the
unpredictable nature of these little
toys usually they're pretty fast and
they're pretty easy to drive but the
thing is that like unlike an actor tell
them to do something or improve it it's
like it's all about your actual skills
as a driver that need to start rapidly
improving it's not useful footage but we
thought it'd be like maybe a two-day
shoot turn into a five-day shoot it
obviously became one of our longest
shoots could ever done for our YouTube
channel say 5 4 up never thought RC cars
would take this long to shoot
when watching the video you can properly
sense there's some sort of like Mad Max
or a road warrior vibes and that's
because the video was originally kind of
conceptualized around that idea of like
a desert convoy of of these like Mad Max
and he's like little like road vehicles
that are all like bulky and you know
kind of modded out and with batteries
instead of guessing yeah exactly but as
we started shooting it and started
editing it and we actually use the song
from carpenter brut he's a really great
french electronic artist and the moment
we drop that in there suddenly the
entire cone of peace change no longer
was like road warrior is a little more
like 80s kids movie kind of done like
John Xtreme on steroids one of the
challenges with shooting something like
this is getting that same look that
you'd have in real car chase so we have
to get the camera down on the ground as
low as we can for most of these shots in
order to make them seem right right and
so there's a couple different ways we
did that one is we actually dig holes
and stick our little high hat with the
red into those holes so the red was at
ground level a lot of fishing line used
in this piece whether it's for
explosions and trying to get cars to
flip and accidents or oddly enough
because it's so hard to coordinate so
many RC cars at once sometimes we'd
actually just attach strings to most of
the cars and drag them all at the same
time one thing that might be lingering
with you guys after watching this video
is how did you do those insane
explosions those explosions and those
lasers and that stuff blowing up looks
so cool and well you're right it does
look very cool it's the blend of the VFX
elements and the practical elements so
we have these laser effects coming down
and a couple blue sparks in there but
for the most part the actual cars
exploding is 100% real one strategy that
we use when approaching this video was
we wanted to do as much stuff
practically as possible that meant very
few effect shots a couple things pan out
like a pan out a pole for that black
helicopter toy painting outlet strings
from a couple shots and it's a couple of
GoPro angles they're super wide so you
can see like Sam in the background like
throwing the car or like holding
something up and so we had to remove him
as well the more complicated shots to
notice there's a shot where this swoops
in front of the camera while following
some other vehicles
that one was actually this flying in
front of a green screen and then we just
composite that because there's no way
for actually to get that shot in real
life of the thing perfectly flying in
front and that's actually how they did
all the spaceship models and stuff in
Star Wars yeah trying to save girls like
don't drive the cars between shots like
this is the best no phony go this is a
set dang it there are many churches not
toys mom I hope you guys learned a
little bit about the shoot here and kind
of the process going into it and if you
have any more questions about it visit
on Twitter or leave a comment below and
maybe subscribe if you haven't already